We now have a respectable
understanding of the periodic
table itself and the
atoms in them.
And now we're ready to deal
with molecules themselves.
And to deal with molecules, we
have to have some way of
representing them.
And you represent them
with formulas.
And there's two major--
actually, three major ways to
represent a molecule.
One is the molecular formula.
And the other is the
empirical formula.
And I'll do it in a different
color to differentiate it.
And the difference is, well,
let's just talk about what the
word empirical means.
I remember when I first took
chemistry the teacher kept
using the word empirical.
Well, what does empirical
really mean?
I clearly did not have a
very deep vocabulary.
I forgot what age I was.
But it means achieved through
observation or experiment, or
based on experience.
So if someone said that they
empirically figured out x, y,
or z, it means that they figured
it out through an
experiment or they
observed it.
The molecular formula is
essentially the actual number
of atoms in that molecule.
Let me show you what
I'm talking about.
So the empirical formula tells
you what people have observed.
Maybe before they even knew that
there was such a thing as
atoms, what they would have
observed is the ratio of the
atoms to one another in a
molecule without knowing in
the exact molecule how many
of that atom there are.
Let me show you what
I'm talking about.
So if I were to give you, I
don't know, a benzene, the
molecular formula of benzene,
you have 6 carbon atoms and
you have 6 hydrogen atoms. Now,
if you were some chemist
in the 1800's and you didn't
know about the actual atoms,
but if you had a big bag of
benzene and you were to
measure the ratio of the carbon
to the hydrogen that
you had in that bag, you would
find out that for every one
carbon you have one hydrogen.
So your empirical formula
is the ratio of the two.
You don't know that each atom
actually has 6 of these, but
you know that for every carbon,
there's a hydrogen.
And for every hydrogen
there's a carbon.
And the way to go back, you
can go from the molecular
formula to the empirical
formula very easily.
You just find the greatest
common divisor of the number
of atoms in the molecule.
So the greatest common divisor
is six, and six is obviously
six, you divide both of these
by six and you get the
empirical formula.
It's not easy.
You pretty much can't go back
from the empirical formula to
the molecular formula.
You've lost information.
I don't know whether
this was C6H6.
Was it C2H2?
You just don't know.
And I mentioned right at the
beginning of the video that
there's a third way to
represent molecules.
And that's the structural
formula.
And we'll do that, off and on,
and we've already done it a
little bit.
Let me show you.
The structural formula for
benzene would actually say how
the molecular formula atoms
are configured.
So benzene in particular
is very interesting.
It looks like this.
It's often drawn like this.
And you'll see this a lot when
you take organic chemistry.
But it looks like a little
hexagon, where the vertices of
the hexagon are carbon atoms.
So let me draw the carbon
atoms in yellow.
So this is carbon,
carbon, carbon,
carbon, carbon, carbon.
They have double bonds,
every other carbon.
Double bonds.
And then they have single
bonds to hydrogen.
Let me just do the hydrogen
in another color.
Let me do it in magenta.
Hydrogen.
And obviously, the structural
formula gives you the most
information.
Right?
Then you can start to think
about, gee, how will this
interact with other things?
While the molecular formula just
tells you what's in the
molecule, the empirical formula
really gives you the
least information.
It just tells you the ratio
of the different
items in the molecule.
Structural formula.
Let's do a couple more.
OK, what if we're dealing with,
let's say we're dealing
with water.
I think you know the molecular
formula for water.
H2O.
Now what would be the empirical
formula for this?
Well we want to know the ratio,
so for every oxygen
there's two hydrogens.
Or I guess you could say
for every hydrogen
there's a half of oxygen.
So you can't reduce this.
If I wrote this as H2O1, what's
the greatest common
divisor of 2 and 1?
Well, it's 1, so you just have
to divide them by 1.
So in this case, the empirical
and the molecular formula are
the exact same thing.
It's H2O.
What about sulfur?
And an interesting molecule,
because obviously,
it's just one atom.
Sulfur.
Sorry, no, I'm spelling
it wrong.
No.
No, it's not a p h, it's f.
Clearly, I shouldn't be making
spelling videos.
So sulfur.
So the molecular formula S8.
So it forms this neat kind of
octagon-looking chain of sulfurs.
And if I were to draw that,
you would see that.
And you could look it up on
Wikipedia, if you like.
But its empirical formula, if
you had just a bag of sulfur,
you don't know that each
atom has eight sulfurs.
You just have a big
bag of sulfur.
So, the imperative formula,
there's only one
atom in this molecule.
You divide by eight
and you get S.
So you just know that all you've
got there is sulfur.
So let's just do one more.
Glucose.
I'll pick a new color.
The molecular formula
is C6H12O6.
So for every carbon,
there are how many?
For every 6 carbons, there's
12 hydrogen and 1 oxygen.
So if you kind of reduce this
formula to its empirical form,
what do you get?
Let's see, you can divide all
these numbers by 6, so we get
1 carbon, 2 hydrogens,
and 1 oxygen.
So this just tells you the ratio
that they exist in a big
bag of this molecule.
This tells you the
exact number of
atoms in that molecule.
Fair enough.
So now we know a little bit
of the difference between
molecular formula, and empirical
formula, and
structural formula.
Now let's see if we can use
what we know about the
formulas and the periodic table
to think a little bit
about the composition, the mass
composition, of some of
these molecules.
So the first thing to even think
about is, how do you
figure out the molecular mass?
Right?
I have my little periodic
table down there.
So molecular mass.
So the first question is, how
do you figure out-- I mean,
the molecular mass is going to
be the sum of all of the atoms
in that molecule, right?
So if you wanted to know the
molecular mass of-- let's say
you wanted to know
how much does one
molecule of benzene mass?
I don't want to say weight,
because it should be
independent of what
planet you're on.
So what is the mass of one
molecule of benzene?
Well, all you do is you add up
the masses of the different
constituents.
So you have 6 carbons
and 6 hydrogens.
So let's do benzene.
You have 6 carbons
and 6 hydrogens.
So what's the mass
of each carbon?
So let's go back down to
the periodic table.
Just to give proper credit, I
got this off of the Los Alamos
National Laboratories website.
So let's see, the atomic
mass of carbon.
The reason why I used this one
instead of my previous one is
my previous periodic table that
I got off Wikipedia only
had atomic numbers on them.
But now that we're actually
going to start talking about
the mass composition
of different atoms
or different molecules.
We're going to have to
start looking at the
atomic mass, right?
Remember, the atomic mass, when
you think about atomic
mass units, it's just the number
of protons plus the
number of neutrons.
So you have six protons
in carbon
and roughly six neutrons.
And why is there this decimal?
Because, as we said before, this
is an average of all of
the masses of the isotopes
you'll find of carbon.
So there's a little bit of
carbon 14 on the planet, very
little, but most of the
carbon is carbon 12.
When you proportionately average
them, you get 12.01.
But let's say we're dealing with
carbon 12, just because
that's the most common
element.
Carbon is 12 atomic
mass units.
Right?
And atomic mass units
is a unit of mass.
And we'll talk about
how small it is.
It's a very, very, very,
very small fraction
of a gram or kilogram.
And we'll talk about that,
probably in the next video.
So carbon is 12 atomic
mass units.
What about hydrogen?
Let's see.
We go to our periodic table.
Hydrogen is here in
this dark blue.
And I don't know if you can
read it, but this is
interesting, the atomic number
of hydrogen is 1.
The atomic mass of hydrogen
is 1.0008.
So that tells us that most of
the hydrogen on this planet
has an atomic mass of 1.
Which tells us that it
essentially has no neutrons.
That hydrogen is a kind of an
interesting nucleus there,
where there is really
just a proton.
Just a proton sitting
in that nucleus.
And so if you were to
ionize hydrogen.
If you were to turn into a
cation and take one of its
electrons away, what
are you left with?
You just have a proton.
A proton sitting by itself, just
a single proton, really
is no different than
a hydrogen ion.
And that to me is kind
of interesting.
That hydrogen is that simple.
It's really just a proton.
So hydrogen has an
atomic mass of 1.
Right?
If it had any neutrons in it, it
would have been at least an
atomic mass of 2.
But hydrogen has atomic
mass of 1.
One atomic mass unit.
So what is the mass of one
molecule of benzene?
Well it's 6 times
the carbon mass.
6 times 12 plus 6 times
the mass of hydrogen.
Plus 6 times 1.
So that is 6 times 12, is 72,
plus 6 times 1, plus 6, is
equal to 78.
Now, what if someone
said, what percent
of benzene is carbon?
Well then you say, OK, this
is the piece that's
carbon, right here.
The carbon piece of benzene
is 72 atomic mass units.
Right, that's carbon.
So what percentage of
benzene is carbon?
Well it's 72 over 78.
The whole thing is 78.
So it's 72 over 78.
And what does that equal?
Let me get a calculator going.
I should've had my calculator
open ahead of time.
All right.
So 72 divided by 78
is equal to 92.3%.
So benzene is 92.3%
carbon by mass.
And of course, the remainder,
the 7.7%,
is going to be hydrogen.
Let's do that for a couple of
these other guys down here.
So let's say we wanted to
know what is the mass of
a molecule of water?
Fair enough.
There's enough water on the
planet, if you want to know
what that is.
Well we already know what the
mass of a hydrogen is.
It's 1.
Right?
Hydrogen is 1.
One atomic mass unit.
Oxygen is what?
Oxygen is 16.
Notice, it's exactly 16.
So on most of the planet, you
pretty much have, in an oxygen
atom, you have 8 protons
and exactly 8 neutrons.
So you get an atomic
mass of 16.
So oxygen has an atomic mass
of 16 atomic mass units.
So the atomic mass of the entire
molecule, you have 2
hydrogens, so you have 2 times
the mass of hydrogen plus 1
oxygen-- plus 16-- so that
equals 18 atomic
mass units for water.
And once again, if you want to
say, what percent by mass of
water is oxygen?
Well it's 16 out of
the 18, right?
Is oxygen.
So if we get the calculator
back, you get 16
divided by 18 is water.
So, let's say you round
it, 88.9% water.
Sorry, 88.9% oxygen.
So most of water is oxygen.
And this is interesting, even
though you have two hydrogens
here, two hydrogens for every
one oxygen, oxygen's mass is
so much larger-- it's 16
times larger-- that
most of water is oxygen.
Well, I'm probably running out
of time, so the next video I'm
going to talk about how
do we go backwards.
If someone gives you the
composition, how can you get
the empirical formula.
Actually on a side note,
slightly unrelated to what I
just talked about, I was doing
some research last night about
metals, because they're actually
interesting, about
why some metals conduct more
and some conduct less.
Because when I first talked
about, you know, these were
obviously the transition
metals.
They're backfilling
their d orbitals.
And I said, hey, the periodic
table that was in-- I think I
was looking in a Princeton
Review book that described
these as metals and described
these as transition metals.
And I was like, hey, you know,
that's kind of not fair,
because I consider iron and
copper and gold and silver to
be as metallic as anything.
Why should these be called
transition metals and these be
just called regular metals.
And it actually turns out that
a common name for these are
poor metals.
Poor metals.
Because, to a large degree,
they're softer, they have
lower melting points, so the
intuition was right.
To a large degree, when we think
of metals, these are the
metals I think of.
And when we think of metallic
nature in a chemistry sense--
we talked a lot about that,
who wants to donate their
electrons the most, that's
metallic nature.
They're the guys down here.
And as you go to the top right,
these want to donate
their electrons the least.
These are the most
electronegative.
They like electrons the most, so
they actually have some of
the worst metallic nature, so
it actually makes sense to
call them poor metals.
And there's some debate on
whether these should even be
called poor metals.
If you look up a bunch of
periodic tables, some will
call these metals.
Some will call these
poor metals.
But I just wanted to throw that
out there just so you're
exposed to it.
And so, you know, for me, it is
a little bit more intuitive
to call these poor metals,
because they have less
metallic nature than the stuff,
especially down here,
the alkali and the alkaline
earth metals.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.